after a slow start for team gb
this man stepped into the fray adam
petey
the british bullet train cruising
through his heat
the new moustache not slowing him down
and he goes for gold
on monday the team gb women's
footballers are into the quarterfinals
ellen white again the scorer as they
beat japan one nil
and how's this for a punch carris
harting stall from macclesfield
landing a big opening night win but
peter mcgrail from liverpool
who had hoped for a medal went out after
his first fight
in the road race gary thomas pulled out
after a collision
adam yates was the best place british
rider in ninth
andy murray and his doubles partner joe
salisbury had a good first day win
and helen glover is back she's had three
children since winning gold in rio
but she and polly swann got through to
the semi-finals
she's made history by being the first
mother in the british ruling team
to compete at olympic games and now she
wants to make a little bit more history
with polly swann so
we've got a couple of big moral races
coming up for them and i think we'll
just take it one day at a time
the dutch rower finn florian has tested
positive for covid after he competed in
the single skulls on friday
and the overall number of cases amongst
games participants
continues to rise the threat of
disruption doesn't just come from
kovid because there's now a tropical
storm approaching japan
and already some of the outdoor events
like rowing are moving their schedules
around
to try and avoid it china took the very
first gold medal of these games
team gb will start catching up but not
just yet
tom parmenter sky news tokyo